[Music]
[Music]
so before I became a dermatologist III
started in general medicine as as most
dermatologists do in Britain at the end
of that time I went off to Australia
about 20 years ago what you learn when
you go to Australia is the Australians
are very competitive and and they are
not magnanimous in victory and and that
happened a lot Anupama is you can't play
cricket rugby I I could accept that but
moving into work and we have each week
what's called a journal Club when you'd
sit down with the other doctors and
you'd study a scientific paper in
relation to medicine and after week one
it was about cardiovascular mortality a
dry subject how many people die of heart
disease what the rates are and they were
competitive about this you Pommies
you're rates of heart disease are
shocking and of course they were right
Australians have about 1/3 less heart
disease than we do less deaths from
heart attacks heart failure less strokes
they're generally healthier Bunch and
because they said this was because of
their fine moral standing their exercise
because they're Australians and we're we
easy Pommies and so on but you know it's
it's not just Australia that has better
health than Britain within Britain um
there is a gradient of health I this is
what's called standardized mortality
basically your chances of dying this is
looking at data from the paper about 20
years ago but it's true today comparing
your rates of dying at 50 degrees north
that's the South that's London and
places um by latitude and 55 degrees the
bad news is that's here glascott I'm
from Edinburgh worse news that's even
Edinburgh okay so there is
so what accounts for this horrible space
here between us up here in southern
Scotland and the south now we know about
smoking deep-fried Mars bars trips the
glass codes are all of these things but
this graph is after taking into account
all of these known risk factors this is
after accounting for smoking social
class diet all those other known
respects we are left with this missing
space of increased deaths the further
north you go now sunlight of course
comes into this and vitamin D has had a
great deal of press and a lot of people
get concerned about it and we need
vitamin D it's now a requirement that
children have a certain amount my
grandmother grew up in Glasgow back in
the 1920s and 30s when rickets was a
real problem and cod liver oil was
brought in and that really prevented the
rickets that used to be common in this
city and I as a child was fed cod liver
oil by my grandmother I distinctly
nobody forgets cod liver oil but an
association the higher people's blood
levels of vitamin D are the less heart
disease they have the less cancer there
seems to be a lot of data suggesting
that vitamin D is very good for you and
it is to prevent rickets and so on but
if you give people vitamin D supplements
you don't change that high rate of heart
disease and the evidence for preventing
cancers is not yet great so what I'm
going to suggest is that vitamin D is
not the only story in town it's not the
only reason preventing heart disease
high vitamin D levels I think are a
marker for sunlight exposure and
sunlight exposure in methods I'm going
to show is good for heart disease anyway
I came back from Australia and despite
the obvious risks to my health I moved
to Aberdeen
now in Aberdeen I started my dermatology
training but I also became interested in
research and in particular I became
interested in this substance nitric
oxide now these three guys up here first
got ignarro Murad won the Nobel Prize
for medicine back in 1998 and they were
the first people to describe this new
chemical transmitter nitric oxide what
nitric oxide does is it dilates blood
vessels so lowers your blood pressure it
also dilates the coronary arteries stops
angina and what was remarkable about it
was in the past when we think of
chemical messengers within the body we
thought of complicated things like
estrogen and insulin or nerve
transmission very complex processes with
very complex chemicals that fit into
very complex receptors and here's this
incredibly simple molecule on nitrogen
and an oxygen that has stuck together
and yet these are hugely important for
painting our low blood pressure for
neurotransmission for many many things
but particularly cardiovascular health
and I saw sting research and we found
very excitingly that the skin produces
nitric oxide so it's not just in the
cardiovascular systems arises it arises
in the skin while having found that and
published that I thought well what's it
doing how do you have a low blood
pressure in your skin you know it's not
the heart what do you do so I went off
to the States as many people do if
they're going to do research and I spent
a few years in Pittsburgh um
this is Pittsburgh and I was interested
in these really kind of complex systems
we thought that maybe nitric oxide
affected cell death and how cells
survive and their resistance to other
things and I first of all started
working in cell culture growing cells
and then as using knockout mouse models
mice that couldn't make me the gene we
worked out a mechanism which I know was
helping cells survive and I then moved
back to Edinburgh and in Edinburgh the
experimental animal we use is the
medical student it's a species close to
human with several advantages over mice
they're free you don't shave them they
feed themselves and nobody pickets your
office saying save the lab medical
student so they're really an ideal an
ideal model
but what we found was that we couldn't
reproduce in man the data we had shown
in mice it seemed we couldn't turn off
the production of nitric oxide in the
skin of humans we put on creams that
block the enzyme that made it and we
injected things we couldn't turn off the
the micro coxide and the reason for this
it turned out after two or three years
work was in the skin we have huge stores
not of nitric oxide because nitric oxide
is a gas and it's released and in a few
seconds it's away but it can be turned
into these forms of nitric oxide nitrate
no3 nitrite no.2 my tracer thousand
these are more stable and your skin has
got really large stores of Na and we
then thought to ourselves well those big
stores
I wonder if sunlight might activate
those stores and release them from the
skin where the stores are about ten
times as big as what's in the
circulation could the Sun activate those
stores into the circulation and they're
in the circulation and can do it's good
things for your cardiovascular system
well I'm an experimental dermatologist
so what we did was we thought we have to
expose our experimental animals to
sunlight and so what we did was we took
a bunch of volunteers and we expose them
to ultraviolet light so these are kind
of Sun lamps now what we were careful to
do was vitamin D is made by ultraviolet
B rays and we wanted to separate our
story from the vitamin D story so we
used ultraviolet a which doesn't make
vitamin D when we put people under a
lamp for the equivalent of about thirty
minutes of sunshine in summer in
Edinburgh what we produced was refused
to rise in circulating nitric oxide so
we put patients with these subjects
under the UV and then enno levels do go
up and their blood pressure goes down
not by much as an individual level but
enough at a population level to shift
the rates of heart disease in a whole
population and when we Shawn UV at them
or when we warmed them up to the same
level as the Lambs but didn't actually
that the
hit the skin this didn't happen so this
seems to be a feature of ultraviolet
rays hitting the skin now we're still
collecting data a few good things here
were this appeared to be more marked in
older people I'm not sure exactly how
much one of the subjects here was my
mother-in-law and clearly I do not know
her age but certainly in people older
than my wife
this appears to be a more marked effect
and the other thing I should mention was
there was no change in vitamin D this is
separate from vitamin D so vitamin D is
good for you it stops rickets it
provides calcium italo's important stuff
but this is a separate mechanism from
vitamin D now one of the problems were
looking at blood pressure is your body
does everything it can to keep your
blood pressure at the same place if your
leg is dropped off and you lose blood
your body will clamp down increase the
heart rate do everything it can to keep
your blood pressure up that is an
absolutely fundamental physiological
principle so what we've next done is
we've moved on to looking at blood
vessel dilatation so we've measured this
is again notice no tail and and hairless
this is a medical student okay in the
arm you can measure how blood flow in
the arm by how much it swells up as some
blood flows into it and what we've shown
is adding a sham irradiation this is the
thick line here this is shining UV on
the arms that warms up but keeping it
cupboards the Rays don't hit the skin
there is no change in blood flow in in
dilatation of the blood vessels
but the active irradiation during the UV
and for an hour after it there is
dilation of the blood vessels this is
the mechanism by which you lower blood
pressure by which you dilate the
coronary arteries also to let the blood
be supplied with heart so here further
data that ultraviolet that sunlight has
benefits on the blood flow and the
cardiovascular system so we thought we'd
just kind of model the different amounts
of UV hit the earth at different parts
of the earth at different times of year
so you can actually work out those
stores of nitric oxide the nitrates
might write smite Rosa tiles on the skin
release a cleave to release air no
different wavelengths of light have
different activities at doing that so
you can look at the wavelengths of light
that do that and you can look
so if you live on the equator the Sun
comes straight overhead it comes to a
very thin bit of atmosphere and winter
or summer it's the same amount of light
if you live up here in summer the sun's
coming fairly directly down but in
winter it's coming through a huge amount
of atmosphere and much of the
ultraviolet is weeded out and that range
of wavelengths he earth are different in
summer to winter so what you can is you
can multiply those data by the n oh
that's released and you can calculate
how much nitric oxide would be released
from the skin into the circulation now
if you're on the equator here that's
these two lines here the red line and
the Purple Line and the amount of nitric
oxide that's released is the area under
the curve is the area in this space here
so if you're on the equator December or
June they've got masses of n O being
released from the skin so Ventura is in
Southern California in summer you might
as well be at the equator it's great
lots of n o is released for interior
midwinter well it's still you know a
decent amount Edinburgh in summer the
area beneath the curve is pretty good
but Edinburgh in winter you know the
amount of air no that can be released is
next to nothing tiny amounts so what do
we think we're still working at this
story we're still developing it with
still expanding it we think it's very
important and we think it probably
accounts for a lot of the north-south
health divide within Britain it's of
relevance to us we think that the skin
well we know that the skin has got very
large stores of nitric oxide disease
various other forms we suspect a lot of
these come from diet green leafy
vegetables beet roots
lettuce has a lot of these nitric oxides
that we think go to the skin we think
they're then stored in the skin and we
think the sunlight releases this where
it has generally beneficial effects and
this is ongoing work but I mean
dermatologists I mean I'm a
dermatologist my day job is saying to
people you've got skin cancer it's
caused by sunlight don't go in the Sun I
actually think a far more important
message is that there are benefits as
well as risks to sunlight yes sunlight
is the is the major alterable risk
factor for skin cancer but deaths from
heart disease are a hundred times higher
than deaths from skin cancer
and I think that we need to be more
aware of and we need to find the
risk-benefit ratio how much sunlight is
safe how can we kind of finesse this
best for our general health
so thank you very much indeed
[Applause]